خالد المظفر نجم الكوميديا بيشارك هذا
الموسم الرمضاني الحالي في استوديو 23
واللي سبق وشارك في اجزاءه السابقه
استوديو 22 استوديو 21 كمان
جديد مشاهدينا الكرام برنامجنا اعمل خير
وقطه
وين
اول مره
هذه
[تصفيق]
الفريق
[موسيقى]
وايد اكبر من الحدث
بيشارك في بطوله استديو 23 سنه فهو كمان
بيقوم ببطوله مسلسل اخر اللي هو سقط سهوا
واللي هو كمان صاحب فكرته شارك في التاليف
وكمان وبيشاركوا في بطولته وفنان
الكوميديا المصري حمدي المرغني وبيتكلم
العمل عن صديقين بتصير معاهم كثير من
الاحداث ليش اسمه سقط سهوا راح نعرف مع
بعض بس بعد ما نشوف برومو العمل
الدكتور ولا علامة علي بيومي الحاصل على
علامه الايزو في علم النفس اصحى يا حبيبي
اصحيكم ترى احنا هني بالمستشفى عباره عن
فمل انا غني ممكن تصمينا لمحنا قاعدين
بالنا شويه حلوين وبنتسامر وبنشرب قهوتنا
امال مين بيعالج العيانين
وينضم الينا من الكويت النجم خالد المظفر
اهلا فيك معنا خالد كل عام وانت بالف خير
اهلا كل عام وانتم بخير يا ساره ومبارك
على الشهر ومبارك على اخواننا واخواتنا
الساده المشاهدين
بالصحه والعافيه يا رب يا هلا فيك اجمعين
اجمعين وانت ما شاء الله السنه متالق
بعملين خلينا نبتدي باستديو 23 عوده مره
اخرى لاستوديو 23 مبسوطين انتم يعني
عالنجاح
اللهم لك الحمد والله هذه هي التجربه
الثالثه في عمل استوديو 23 مع اخواني
النجوم اخوي حبيب الحبيب عبد العزيز
النصار وخالد الفراج وماجد المطرب وسامي
حازم وجميع الاخوه والفنانين والفنانات
اللي شاركوا في جميع الفقرات للامانه
العمل كوميدي بسيط الناس حابته بعفويته
بفغراته يعني فاحنا سنه مع سنه نجدد العهد
مع شاشه العرب ام بي سي ان احنا نقدم هذا
العمل الكوميدي الهدف منه هو فقط الضحكه
والابتسامه
اتمنى الكل ياخذها بصدر الرحم لا طبعا وهو
اصلا انتم اليوم من اول حلقه ترند
والمقاطع الجلسه بتنزل من الحلقه ما شاء
الله عليكم بس انا انت قلت ذكرت اسماء
طبعا فريق العمل وكل التحيه لهم كلهم نجوم
رائعين انا احس انه كواليس التصوير تضحك
اكثر من التصوير نفسه
[ضحك]
لا كلامك صح 100% لان انت قاعد تتعامل مع
كوميديانات يعني وكل واحد لكن اكثر الخاص
فيه يعني عبد العزيز النصار مع حبيب
الحبيب وماجد مطرب يعني
مقالب او يخرب المشاهد فيكم من اكثر واحد
لا هو بصراحه يعني اكثر واحد احنا عندنا
حركه ما شاء الله عليه الله يحفظه اخونا
حبيب الحبيب احنا نجد تصوير احيانا ثمان
الصبح يكون يعني مالنا خلق نسلم على بعض
نشوف حبيب ما شاء الله
عليها حبيبي وطبعا تحيه
يعني برضو من الشخصيات الرائعه جدا اذا
بدي انا اخوي يعني عبد العزيز النصار اوجه
له تحيه خصوصا اغلب مشاهد كانت مع وانا
استمتع لما امثل مع عبد العزيز للامانه
اذا نقلتك على سقط سهوا لانه هو اللي عمل
اللي جديد بالنسبه لك يعني هذا الموسم اول
شيء ليش اسمه سقط سهوا
سقط سهوا لانه فعلا نحن في شغلات بحياتنا
تكون سقطه سهوا ما كانت هي عن عمد ما
فعلناها واحنا متعمدين
فسقط سهوا هي الكلمه اللي تلخص الحدوته
واللي قاعد يصير بين الشخصيات سقطت سهوا
عمل كوميدي لايت
دراما راح يكون فيه مكس
اجواء جديده على الاعمال الكوميديه دائما
العمل الكوميدي تعودنا عليه بالسنين
الاخيره انه يكون اغلبك
يعني شنو شايفه يا ساره يعني اكيد انت يا
خالد صح اكيد انت اللي حبيبي حتكون حتقول
انت المؤلف والمنتج
بسيط عادي الشغله هذه الشغله نسيتها اكيد
يعني طبعا حتضبط الامور انه كل البنات
تحبك انت اكيد يعني
احنا كل مشهد نصور يقول لي حمدي حمدي يقول
لي ايه يا عمو خلود
لانه شايف الوضع يعني طب التعاون مع حمدي
اصلا
للامانه هو التعاون انا للامانه يعني من
معجبين فرغت مسرح مصر الفرقه اللي اسسها
الاستاذ الكبير اشرف عبد الباقي من خلالها
تعرفنا على النجوم اللي هما محمد عبد
الرحمن توته مصطفى خاطر كلهم نجوم كبار
طبعا علي ربيع حمدي مرغني كل الفنانين
الامانه يعني ما احب انسى احد فيهم
كانت الفكره ان احنا فعلا يعني دايما اغلب
السنين اللي طافت كنت اعمل دويتو مع
الفنانين اللي بيشبهوني او بنفس دائرتي
كان دايما عندي طموح انه لا ممكن احنا
نعمل عمل ويكون معانا كوميديان بحجم
الفنان الكبير حمدي مرغني ويكون
المكس بين الشخصيتين راكب على الاثنين مش
انه فقط مصري بيمثل مع كويتي ويصير فيهات
على اللهجه لا كان كل شيء مرسوم كنا واحنا
قاعد نقرا الورق في بروفه الطاوله كنا
قاعد نضحك وهذا كان مؤشر حلو ويوم طبقناها
على ارض الواقع المشاهد كنا ايضا قاعد
نضحك فان شاء الله الجمهور يستمتع معانا
بهذه التجربه تجربه كانت بالنسبه لنا
كبيره وكنا قاعد نشتغل لها من قلب والفنان
يعني خالد
لا هو يشوف الامانه يعني الحمد لله يقول
لك بعد التعب ان شاء الله يكون نجاح يا رب
فاحنا انا دائما بكل تجربه احب اكون مخلص
واسوي كل شيء على اكمل وجه وكانت للامانه
هي فكره حمدي مرغني والفنان مصطفى خاطر
كان يقول ان انت يا خالد نجم في الكويت
والخليج واحنا معنا الوطن العربي وشمال
افريقيا فلما يكون هذا حلو انه يكون في
عمل يوحد لاثنين صح ان شاء الله تجربت
تنال على اعجابكم ان شاء الله يا رب انت
كاتب هذا العمل او كاتب فكرته من اول من
2015 حسب ما فهمت
صحيح ليش التاخير اذا في هذا كله
والله الامانه يعني يعني خالد المظفر اللي
ب 2023 اكيد هو مو نفس اللي ب 2015
2015 هذه الفكره انا كنت
قروها وايد الفنانين كبار قروها شركات
مونتاج لكن ما كان في احد مؤمن بهذا
الفكره او هذا النص النهوه يرى النور او
ان الفكره حلوه لكن من ثم يوم قررنا انه
يكون معنا الفنان حمدي مرغني فعملت ورشه
مع الاستاذ عبد العزيز سفر وهو لكتب
السيناري والحوار
وعدنا اعداد للناس واعداد لشخصيات وحاولنا
اخلي الشخصيات انضج ونخلي المواقف احلى
وطبيعي يمكن احنا كاتب انا نوعيه من
الكوميديا 2015 مش نفسها هي الحين 2023
ما كان جاهز انه هو يقدم هذا العمل لانه
هو مش عملكم
ب 2015
سنه الان صح
صح 26 ب 2015
كل اللي عندي هنا
لفيت عليهم
يا خالد انا بقول لك من الان
تخلص بقى اذا ما
تخلص منهم من
قدام
احنا كده
حيكون شويه صعب يعني يكون للبنات تحبك
يعني
بس يعني
قعدت مع نفسك طب اسمع خالد انا احس انه
يعني قديش الان صعب انه الواحد يثبت نفسه
في هذا الوسط يعني ما هو سهل المنافسه
شديده في اسماء جدا كبيره خلاص مسيطره على
السوق شركات انتاج معينه نجم شاب زيك ايش
يقدر يعمل عشان يخترق هذا السوق
للامانه يعني بكل بساطه اقولها لك ساره
انا خالد مؤمن بالله سبحانه وتعالى بكل
خطوه ومؤمن ان النجاحي من الله ومؤمن انه
على قد ما انت تتعب على قد ما انت تاخذ
انا اليوم خالد ممكن على قولتش ممثل شاب
قاعد اجتهد لاني محسوب على شركه لاني
محسوب على جهه انتاجيه قاعد نقاتل احنا
اليوم كشباب انه مقدم احلى شيء اللهم لك
الحمد ثمره هذا التعب انه التلفزيون
الكويت اخذ عمل سقطه سهوا وهو العمل
الكوميدي من بين نجوم كبار هذه الثقه ما
يشكرون عليها ايضا شركه ام بي سي ان اليوم
تعطينا الفرصه في عمل ستوديو 23 وايضا
معانا اعمالكم كبار هذا كله يخلي عندنا
مسؤوليه يمكن في واحد شاب ثاني غير يساره
يستانس يفرح لكن انا اشعر بالمسؤوليه
والخوف
ما هو القادم
شنو بتسوي عشان انت تحافظ على هذا الشيء
لكن انا دائما احب اكون اكتف وشغال لا ما
شاء الله عليك يعني
حتى ما شاء الله في مجال المسرحيات يعني
خالد الفتره الاخيره كل مالك بتحاول تعمل
مسرحيات واشياء من هذا النوع بس انت لفتره
طويله يعني ارتبط اسمك بطارق العلي طبعا
النجم الكبير يعني له التحيه طبعا وحسن
البلام طبعا له التحيه
هل بتحس نفسك لازلت اسير لهم او انك انت
ابن هذه المدرسه حقتهم فانت بتكمل فيها
ولا بتحس انك خلاص خرجت من هذه العباءه
لا والله بالعكس يعني الاثنين اللي انت
تكلمتي عنهم وهم قراب من القلب سواء
الفنان الكبير طارق العلي والفنان الكبير
حسن البلام انا تعلمت منهم واستفدت منهم
ولا كنت انا راح اقدر كخالد اليوم اني
اكون قائد لعمل كوميدي سواء في المسرح او
في التلفزيون الا من خلال احتكاك مع
الكبار ما راح تكون عندي هذه الكاريزما
ولا القدره الا انه انا محتك معاهم وطحت
في تجارب كثيره والسكت من تجربتهم وعلموني
اللي تعلمته منهم وهو اللي الحين انا قاعد
احاول اطبقه مع الفنانين الشباب اللي معاي
قال احاول اطبقه على نفسي قبل لا طبقه
معاهم فبالعكس يعني حتى لو انا دائما
بالطريق
انا انا يعني هذه نقطتي ان انا من مدرسه
طارق العلي وتعلمت منه واستفدت منه وايضا
الفنان الكبير حسن البلام عنده لون خاص
فيه ومدرسه وتعلمت واستفدت منه لكن انا
دائما شنو اقول هو مش موضوع ان احنا
مدرسه هذا الشخص او هذا الشخص وهو لون
الكوميديا عباره بالنسبه لك الوان اليوم
ابو محمد يقدم لون بو مزيانه يقدم لون
خالد يقدم لون ويجي فنان اخر يقدم
والجمهور لا حريه الاختيار ولو لاحظ
الجمهور قاعد يستمتع مع الكل مع كله مره
كنت في هذا الجواب يا خالد
لا هذه الاسئله خليها بخمسه وعشرين سؤال
لما تيجي صح خلي لما تيجي عندنا
ونمسكك ونلقطك ونسالك ايه لانه كان كذا
جواب دبلوماسي وذكي وارضيتي كل الناس يلا
منتظرينك ان شاء الله عشان ال 25 سؤال
عشان نزنق اكثر في هذه المواضيع خالد
وعد مني انه راح اكون موجود معك
خالد انت من اروع الشخصيات صراحه اللي في
هذا الوسط نتمنى لك كل التوفيق كان معنا
النجم خالد المظفر شكرا
[موسيقى]